North Korea is strengthening ties with
old allies at a parade celebrating the
70th anniversary of the Korean Armistice
Russian and Chinese officials were
guests of honor this display of Unity
comes as Regional Neighbors South Korea
and Japan Step Up military cooperation
with the U.S
if North Korea China and Russia are
under pressure from a democratic
security Alliance led by the United
States it might be that they are trying
to show they have a military security
Alliance to resist it
such as this
asks North Korea's weapons and projects
strength they're also a useful way to
determine pyongyang's military
capability
new attack and surveillance drones
conducted a flyover
also on display was the hwasong 18 an
intercontinental ballistic missile first
unveiled at a parade in February a few
months later North Korea conducted two
tests of the ICBM
Pyongyang has frequently defended its
development of nuclear weapons as a
deterrent
um
the issue is not whether a nuclear war
will break out on the Korean Peninsula
but rather who when and how some will
initiate a nuclear war
last week a U.S nuclear-armed submarine
visited South Korea for the first time
in 40 years North Korea had said then
having such weapons here in South Korea
could justify Pyongyang using nuclear
force and warned the U.S against sending
any more nuclear-capable assets
North Korea declared itself a nuclear
weapon state last year and shows no
indication of stopping its nuclear
ambitions
Florence Louis Al Jazeera Seoul